notre soutien après les jours difficiles
que vous avez connues et vous souhaitez
bien sûr en mon nom mais aussi je le
sais en l'ensemble au nom de l'ensemble
des mes collègues de la commission un un
prompt rétablissement et bien sûr on est
très heureux de vous accueillir dans une
de vos première sortie ici à la
commission ce projet de loi contient
deux projets de loi comprend une
vingtaine d'articles dans la majorité
est issue du projet de loi relatif à la
communication audiovisuelle et à la
souveraineté culturelle à l'ère du
numérique qu'avait élaboré votre
prédécesseur frank riester
l'examen de ce projet de loi a été
interrompue ou du mois au début du mois
de mars 2020 l'issue de son examen par
la commission des affaires culturelles
de l'assemblée nationale le projet de
loi que vous nous présentez aujourd'hui
est bien moins ambitieux que celui de
votre prédécesseur qui comportait une
réforme globale de l'organisation et de
la gouvernance de l'audiovisuel public
cette réforme était attendu et
nécessaire
son abandon a pour conséquence de
limiter les synergies entre les
différentes sociétés de l'audiovisuel
public comme le montre aujourd'hui
l'incapacité de france télévisions et de
radio france à s'entendent pour
développer une offre territoriale
numérique commune la création d'une
gouvernance commune devait permettre de
concevoir une stratégie numérique
audacieuse et puissante pour répondre au
défi des plateformes américaines
son absence devrait durablement
affaiblir le secteur de l'audiovisuel
public et bien entendu nous le
regrettons j'ajoute que la réforme de la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public l'ex
ce redevance aurait dû constituer le
second pilier de la réforme de
l'audiovisuel
cette réforme est également été
abandonnée alors même qu'elle ne
présentait aucune difficulté
particulière si ce n'est la nécessité de
faire entendre raison au ministère des
finances qui a toujours du mal à
reconnaître l'intérêt de préserver
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel public
ceci étant dit le sénat est en saisi en
premier
lecture de votre projet de loi notre
commission l'examinera de manière bien
entendu constructive en tâchant de nous
limiter à son nouveau périmètre qui
porte sur les dispositions relatives à
la régulation du secteur des médias
et d'accès aux oeuvres nous espérons
qu'il sera possible d'enrichir ce texte
pour tenir compte de la nécessité
d'aider nos entreprises à se renforcer
pour produire et diffuser des contenus
aussi attractifs que ceux des
plateformes
si nous arrivons à moderniser notre
réglementation en ce sens ce projet de
loi aura été utile et constituera une
étape importante avant l'indispensable
réforme de la loi de 1986 que notre
commission appelle de ses voeux depuis
2015 avec les propositions nos collègues
jean pierre leleux et andré gattolin
madame la ministre je vais vous le céder
la parole pour une intervention
liminaire à l'issue de laquelle notre
rapporteur sur le texte jean raymond
hugonnet vous posera une première série
de questions et puis je ne doute pas que
par la suite il y aura d'autres
questions des sénateurs ici présents ou
présent à travers ledit essentielle pour
donc être avec vous aujourd'hui pour
vous présenter ce projet de loi relatif
à la régulation et à la protection de
l'accès aux oeuvres culturelles à l'ère
numérique
je dois avouer que ce n'était pas gagné
d'avancé
étant donné que le calendrier vous le
savez est extrêmement est extrêmement
chargé
sans compter que les échéances
électorales à venir vont encore
raccourcir ce calendrier
vous le savez vous l'avez rappelé
d'ailleurs monsieur le président la
crise sanitaire a bouleversé la
poursuite de l'examen du projet de loi
audiovisuel de l'année dernière mais
elle n'a pas diminué cette crise
sanitaire
l'importance des mesures qui étaient
contenues
il a force bien entendu des attentes des
professionnels ou cachés mesure
répondait pour tenir compte du
bouleversement du calendrier
parlementaire
le gouvernement a fait un triple choix
d'une part le recours aux ordonnances la
loi portant diverses dispositions
d'adaptation au droit de l'union
européenne
on permet à si le gouvernement de
transposer plusieurs directives
important pour le secteur culturel
je veux vous remercier à nouveau car je
ne sais bien la difficulté du recours
aux ordonnances pour le parlement
l'ordonance relatives aux services d
louise elle a été promulguée le 21
décembre dernier les ordonnances
permettant de transposer la directive
relative aux droits d'auteur dans le
marché unique numérique et la directive
dite car les satellites sont en
préparation pour une présentation cours
du deuxième trimestre 2010 théâtre en
conseil des ministres d'autres peurs le
gouvernement a choisi de ne pas
reprendre le volet législatif de la
transformation de l'audiovisuel public
mais les objectifs de renforcement des
coopérations entre les différentes
entreprises du service public de
l'audiovisuel ont néanmoins été
confirmés dans les contrats d'objectifs
et de moyens de ces sociétés qui sont en
cours de finalisation
enfin le gouvernement fait le choix de
présenter un nouveau projet de loi
resserré et recentrée sur un nombre de
dispositions plus ou plus restent rares
mais urgent d consensuelle est
susceptible d'être adopté avant la fin
de l'année 2000 21 essais de ce texte
dont nous parlons aujourd'hui trois
enjeux forts structure ce projet de loi
le premier enjeu est le renforcement de
la lutte contre le piratage
ces dispositions trouve une annuité
renforcer dans le contexte de crise
sanitaire en raison des pratiques
culturelles actuelles lanka sur les
pratiques culturelles des français
entend confinement cadets menée par mon
ministère montrent que l'offre numérique
culturelle a été fortement sollicité
pendant cette période confirmant
d'ailleurs une tendance qui n'est pas né
avec la crise sanitaire et qui se dégage
depuis une bonne dizaine d'années mais
cette forte augmentation de la
consommation de biens culturels
numérique dématérialisé s'est
accompagnée d'une hausse des pratiques
illicites
ce qui justifie d'autant plus les
dispositions du projet de loi la lutte
contre le piratage se voit si renforcée
par plusieurs dispositions de fonds
disponibles non pas les internautes mais
les sites internet qui
un profil commercial de la mise en ligne
d'oeuvres en violation des droits des
créateurs
le projet de loi prévoit ainsi que soit
dressé une liste noire des sites
internet dont le modèle économique
repose sur l'exploitation massive de la
contrefaçon
il permet également de lutter plus
efficacement contre les sites miroirs
qui sont les sites qui réapparaissent
sous une autre adresse url après
fermeture d'un site jugé illicite
vous permettrez pardon de prendre de
temps en temps la respiration mes
capacités respiratoires ne sont pas au
top
enfin le projet de loi oui je ne veulent
pas pardon pour cette expression parfois
un peu haché reprenez votre un merci
monsieur le président enfin le projet de
loi prévoit un dispositif spécifique de
référé pour lutter contre le piratage ce
portique la lutte contre le piratage
sportif existe exige la mise en place de
mesures adaptées tenant compte de
l'urgence iron pour retransmission de
remiser leurs directs de manifestations
sportives
c'est pourquoi le projet de loi instaure
un mécanisme album de référé qui est
susceptible de produire des effets
pendant toute la durée de la saison
sportive
ce projet de loi vise donc à accompagner
les internautes dans leurs pratiques
numériques vers des usages responsables
notamment au regard des règles de la
propriété intellectuelle le deuxième
enjeu auquel répond ce projet de loi et
la modernisation de la régulation des
contenus audiovisuels et numériques pour
mener à bien ses nouvelles missions en
matière de lutte contre le piratage mais
aussi pour tenir compte de la
convergence progressive de l'audiovisuel
et du numérique et de la nécessité de
rationaliser l'organisation
administrative en matière de régulation
des contenus
le projet de loi fusionnent
haute autorité pour la diffusion des
oeuvres et la protection des droits sur
internet hadopi et le conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel csa en une nouvelle
autorité de régulation la communication
dionis et numériques arts comme ce
nouveau régulateur spar a compétence sur
l'ensemble du champ de la régulation des
contenus audiovisuels et numériques
il sera aussi mieux armés et plus
efficace grâce à trois évolutions
proposées par le texte
son collège sera récompensé recomposé
par une pensée pour l'instant recompose
des ses missions élargies et ses
pouvoirs de contrôle et d' enquête
étendue
cette modernisation permettra de mieux
réguler les communications sur internet
de protéger les oeuvres culturelles et
de veiller au respect du droit d'auteur
et des droits voisins
enfin le troisième enjeu auquel répond
ce texte c'est la protection de l'accès
du public aux oeuvres cinématographiques
et audiovisuelles françaises
ce chapitre du projet de loi est nouveau
par rapport au texte examiné en mars
2010 à l'assemblée nationale
les catalogues de nos oeuvres
cinématographiques et audiovisuelles
constitue notre patrimoine il forge
notre identité culturelle
ils sont un élément de notre
souveraineté nationale
je pense au film jean renoir de jean
pierre melville d'agnès varda ou encore
évidemment de l'immense bertrand
tavernier qui nous a quittés le 25 mars
dernier
aujourd'hui le public à la garantie
d'avoir accès aux offres françaises car
les producteurs établis en france qui
possèdent ces oeuvres sont tenus à une
obligation de recherche d'exploitation
suivi prévue par le code de la propriété
intellectuelle
cette obligation essentielle leur impose
de conserver les supports des heures en
bon état et de fournir leurs meilleurs
efforts puissent pour que l'oeuvre
puisse être exploité en france et à
l'étranger
or
existe aujourd'hui le risque que de
grandes sociétés de production ou
simplement leur catalogue soit racheté
par des entreprises éloigné de tout
objectif culturel des entreprises
étrangères des fonds d'investissement ah
si les amours ratées par ces entreprises
pourraient du jour au lendemain et rendu
inaccessible au public français
en effet ces acheteurs pourraient
décider de les retirer temporairement du
marché pour en faire monter les prix ou
encore il pourrait décider d'exploiter
seulement les films les plus rentables
dakar et lycées le reste des films en
déshérence
l'article 17 du projet de loi étend donc
à toutes les personnes qui rachète une
ou plusieurs oeuvres françaises
l'obligation de recherche d'exploitation
suivi qui existent aujourd'hui
uniquement pour les producteurs est
amusant france
il prévoit ensuite que tout projet de
cession d'heure doivent faire l'objet
d'une déclaration préalable auprès de
mes services au moins six mois avant la
date de l'opération engagée
ces six mois permettent de vérifier que
l'acheteur présente bien toutes les
garanties pour assurer la recherche
d'exploitations suisses
si ce n'est pas le cas des obligations
garanties sans l'exploitation suivi des
oeuvres françaises de ses catalogues
peuvent lui être imposée pour conclure
cette intervention
je voudrais dire que ce projet de loi
est pour le gouvernement un texte urgent
important et cohérent un texte urgent
car il reprend les dispositions du
projet de loi initial est plus attendu
par les secteurs concernés
en dehors de la transposition des
directives que le gouvernement a été
habilité assurée par voie d'ordonnancé
avec ceux d'un important aussi
ce texte est important car il apporte
des réponses concrètes à trois enjeux
majeurs dans le domaine de la
communication audiovisuelle la
protection des droits
ce 2 août
des producteurs et diffuseurs des
fédérations sportives
l'organisation de notre régulation qui
doit être rationalisés et modernisé et
la défense de l'accès du public aux
oeuvres cinématographiques
audiovisuelles françaises
dans un contexte où la demande d'oeuvre
n'a jamais été aussi forte
c'est enfin un texte cohérent car ses
proches à pitre sont étroitement liés
entre eux la lutte contre le piratage et
la protection des catalogues participe
d'un même objectif celui de défense de
notre création culturelle
elle vise à permettre au public
d'accéder aux oeuvres dans des
conditions respectueuses des droits des
créateurs et il faut un régulateur seul
il aiguille sens pour mettre en oeuvre
les nouveaux outils de lutte contre le
piratage outils innovants outils
ambitieux la création de l'art comme
marque à la fois à la volonté de passer
à la vitesse supérieure de lutte contre
les sites pirates et d'inscrire cette
action dans une politique plus large de
régulation des contenus en ligne
voilà monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs les
quelques mots liminaire que je souhaite
adresser votre commission en amont de
aux échanges
c'est une première étape aujourd'hui je
fais pleinement confiance à la qualité
du travail fourni par monsieur le
rapporteur et par la commission dans son
ensemble pour conserver bien sûr la
cohérence que le gouvernement souhaitait
donner à ce texte met également le
richir à bon escient qui serait en tout
cas comme toujours très attentive au
dialogue avec vous car je suis vous le
savez très attaché au travail
parlementaire
mon équipe et moi même demeurons à votre
entière disposition pour travailler
ensemble sur ce texte et je suis
disponible maintenant monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur pour
répondre à l'ensemble de vos questions
merci mesdames administrés et sans plus
tarder je vais donner la
là j'en rigolais notre rapporteur sur ce
texte pour qu'il vous pose une première
série de questions merci président
bonjour madame la ministre effectivement
très heureux de vous retrouver parmi
nous ma première question portera sur
l'avenir de la plateforme tnt certaines
chaînes s'interrogent aujourd'hui sur
l'avenir de la tnt estime que les
contraintes qui sont attachés sont trop
importantes compte tenu de la baisse de
la part de cette technologie dans les
modes de réception de la télévision
est-ce que ce projet de loi ne pourrait
pas permettre de lever certains
obstacles concernant l'avenir de la tnt
je pense en particulier à la nécessité
pour le cssa de lancer un appel à
candidatures pour le second
renouvellement des autorisations
d'émettre
mais je pense aussi à la possibilité
d'imposer la norme hbbtv sur les
téléviseurs afin de favoriser
l'interactivité sur la tnt
que penseriez-vous d'introduire ce type
d'ajustement dans le projet de loi
ma deuxième question prolonge la
précédente et concerne l'uhd l'ultra
haute définition
le projet de loi ne reprend pas les
dispositions du projet de loi de votre
prédécesseur sur l'expérimentation de
l'uhd quelles en sont les raisons
quel est votre avis sur le hd hertzien
alors que plusieurs chaînes
s'interrogent sur le coût d'une telle
technologie qui nécessiterait de changer
de téléviseur
troisième question elle portera sur les
programmes et plus précisément sur la
réglementation de la production la
situation actuelle est marquée par la
persistance d'une très forte asymétrie
entre les nouveaux acteurs comme netflix
et les acteurs historiques les chaînes
françaises ont besoin de maîtriser les
droits attachés à la production pour
concurrencer les plateformes
que penseriez-vous pour favoriser
l'accès aux oeuvres audiovisuelles
financé par les chaînes du fait d'
établir par exemple une règle de 50 50
50 pour cent de recours à la production
indépendante et 50% de souplesse
permettant aux chaînes de produire en
interne et de conserver les droits
négociés de gré à gré quatrième et
dernière question me concernant elle
concerne la lutte contre le piratage et
vous y avez fait mention fortement
puisque c'est un des objectifs majeurs
le projet de loi procède à la fusion du
csa et de l'hadopi au sein d'un nouveau
régulateur l'art comme ce dernier
devrait bénéficier de deux pouvoirs
supplémentaires avec l'établissement
d'une liste noire et la lutte contre les
lis les sites miroirs pardon mais la
réponse graduée en elle-même n'évolue
qu'à la marge
beaucoup aurait pourtant souhaité
étendre plus encore les pouvoirs du
régulateur notamment par l'institution
d'une transaction pénale établi par
l'art comme pour éteindre l'action
publique suivant en cela les
recommandations d'un rapport d'olivier
dutheillet de lamothe et bethany a gâché
ne serait-il pas temps d'introduire
cette disposition dans notre législation
merci de votre attention ici vous
proposer de répondre à cette première
série de questions et puis après mes
collègues ont d'autres questions à vous
poser mais peut-être cette première
série appelle d'ores et déjà quelques
réponses
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le rapporteur
vous avez posé des questions très
importantes et est très pertinente sur
l' architecture du texte effectivement
votre première question porte sur
l'avenir de la plateforme tnt sur le
périmètre lui même du projet de loi le
gouvernement je voulais dire choisi un
texte resserré pour permettre son examen
dans le peu de temps imparti autour de
mesures qui sont d'une part très attendu
et qui sont d'autre part cohérentes
entre elles
c'est la raison pour laquelle il n'a pas
été décidé d'en entendre certains volets
des projets audiovisuels comme les
dispositions relatives à la
modernisation de la tmp
je sais qu'il y avait une volonté du
sénat
on sait sur ce sujet j'ai eu l'occasion
d'en parler avec vous monsieur le
président à laurent lafon est avec vous
même monsieur le rapporteur et je sais
que la sénatrice morin desailly a déposé
une proposition de loi en ce sens sur le
fond évidemment le gouvernement reste
favorable aux mesures qui étaient
prévues dans le projet de jeu aux
newbies l initiale je ne m'opposerai pas
à ces dispositions sur le fond je
rappelle néanmoins et je veux non sur ce
sujet être complète le risque de tels
amendements est notable qu'il puisse
elle déclaré li recevable au regard de
l'architecturé actuelle du texte ou a
posteriori comme cavalier législatif par
le conseil constitutionnel
j'avais d'ailleurs monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur a plaidé
attention sur ce fait au delà je
regarderai avec bienveillance vos
amendements
j'alerte quand même sur le besoin de
rester le plus possible sur un texte
resserré on m'avait posé également une
question sur la norme hbbtv
c'est une norme très intéressante qui
permet de combiner les avantages de la
diffusion hertzienne ou là et si pardon
et ce ne l'était le csa a lancé des
expérimentations que nous suivons avec
attention
il est trop tôt monsieur le rapporteur
pour envisager d'imposer cette norme aux
équipementiers
elle n'est pas suffisamment déployés par
les éditeurs
ce savant en outre fragile juridiquement
en revanche on a introduit dans l'
ordonnance du 27 décembre 2020 un
principe d'intégrité du signal sur
lequel csa pourrait s'appuyer pour
s'assurer que les distributeurs n'en
doutent pas le signal de l'éditeur
lorsque les celui ci fait le choix de
recourir ou hbbtv
autre question suivante à porter sur lui
a ajouté
il est vrai que le hd ac pour le
producteur qui doit capter en nuage
n'est pour l'éditeur qui doit diffuser
de même qui consomme plus de ressources
même si c'est partiellement compensé par
la progression des normes de compression
est lourd de l'aide des spectateurs qui
est obligé de renouveler les équipements
siens même s'il me faut préciser que la
ville par des téléviseurs de grande
taille mis sur le marché aujourd'hui
sont d'ores et déjà compatibles mais
c'est une question de compétitivité de
la plateforme tnt face aux autres modes
de diffusion qui évolue progressivement
vers l'ue hd et qui ont donc
mécaniquement conduire les
téléspectateurs à s'équiper
il pourrait donc y avoir un risque de
décrochage en termes de qualité perçue
qui fragiliserait l'avenir de la
plateforme
je redis donc mon accord sur le fonds
des dispositions sur le sujet qui
figurait dans le projet de loi initial
et qui sont d'ailleurs aussi dans la
proposition de loi madame morin desailly
mais je redis aussi mes doutes sur la
possibilité d'introduire ces dispositifs
par amendement sans risque de les voir
qualifié de cavalier 1,6 sur la
nécessité de rester à un texte resserrer
le projet de loi ne reprend pas ses
mesures pour les mêmes raisons la
volonté d'un texte resserré avec une
certaine cohérence
votre question suivante monsieur le
rapporteur portait sur la réglementation
de la production c'est une question très
importante que vous posez et vont
pointer à juste titre la question du
rééquilibrage des obligations entre
acteurs historiques et nouveaux entrants
en matière de financement de la
production
ce rééquilibrage est déjà en cours au
niveau législatif nous avons transposé
la directive et c'est ma part lors des
annonces du 21 décembre dernier
ça nous permet désormais d'appliquer
notre régime de contribution à la
production aux chaînes et plateformes de
vidéo à la demande étrangère qui vise
notre territoire on au niveau
réglementaire
un décret d'application de cette
ordonnance type
décret smad qui fixe le nouveau régime
de contribution à la production
d'oeuvres qui s'applique tant au service
relevant de la compétence de la france
qu étranger visant la france est en
cours d'examen au conseil d'état j'ai
par ailleurs invité l'ensemble des
parties prenantes à discuter en vue
d'une révision du décret qui fixe le
régime de contribution à la production
des chaînes de la tnt
le décret terry t il donc jusqu'à fin
avril
qu'on en discute et il faut donc laisser
ce travail se poursuivra le niveau de la
part indépendante ne relève pas
d'ailleurs de la loi j'ajoute que tous
les acteurs historiques ne souhaitent
pas forcément faire baisser ce niveau
certains plaident plutôt pour un
assouplissement de la définition de la
dépendance
mon objectif est donc de construire un
nouveau cadre
assis sur un consensus éditeurs
producteurs j'attends donc de voir quel
sera le résultat des discussions en
cours
enfin votre quatrième question portait
sur la lutte contre le piratage et la
transaction pénale
j'entends bien sûr avec vous la volonté
de certaines parties prenantes d'aller
plus loin
c'est un sujet complexe il y avait
d'ailleurs eu de longs débats sur ce
sujet lors de l'examen du projet de loi
audiovisuel chez vos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
avait alors été défavorable à la
production de 7 dispose de ce dispositif
je crois que ce serait une erreur de se
focaliser sur le mécanisme de réponse
graduée qui ciblent uniquement les
échanges de pair à pair et ignorer les
autres formes de piratage tels de la
lecture en flux ou le téléchargement
direct
ils représentent d'ailleurs la majorité
maintenant et piratage le vrai problème
aujourd'hui ce sont les chiites contre
faisant eux-mêmes qui génèrent des
revenus extrêmement important avec leurs
pratiques illégales
le projet de loi prévoit pour la
première fois des dispositions pour
lutter efficacement contre les chiites
pirates liste noire ne sais si tu pour
favoriser les approches qui permettent
de responsabiliser les entreprises qui
ont des liens commerciaux et les sites
pirates l'ue plus efficace contre les
sites miroirs référé spécifique pour les
compétitions sportives
il permet également grâce à la fusion
cesse à hadopi de créer un régulateur
unique et puissant chargé de la lutte
contre le piratage
le niveau de sensibilité du grand public
sur la question de la répression des
pratiques des internautes restent élevés
je me permets de le rappeler donner le
sentiment d'un durcissement de la
répression me semblerait inopportun en
tout état de cause mais tout
spécialement dans le contexte actuel
le succès de la transaction n'est par
ailleurs en aucune manière garantie il
n'y a aucune incitation pour les
internautes accepté de payer une amende
s'ils n'ont pas la certitude qu'ils
seront poursuivis
en cas de refus de transiger voilà
monsieur le rapporteur
la réponse aux premières questions et je
suis maintenant à disposition de vos
collègues c'est la friche et sénateurs
monsieur le président madame la ministre
commence d'abord par lé vous souhaitez
un rétablissement encore plus grand je
crois que j'étais quelques jours avec
vous quelques jours avant avec vous sur
une école du 20e arrondissement
en tous les cas beaux établissements sur
cette loi
première remarque il n'y a aucune raison
réelle au terme d'agenda quoi qui
justifie vraiment le fait que entre le
moment où ça s'est arrêté à l'assemblée
nationale la discussion de la loi
c'est-à-dire il ya un an et la fin du
quinquennat
on n'est pas trouvé de quoi la faire
passer au sénat puisque la discussion
était quasiment fini à l'assemblée
nationale donc c'est peut m'expliquer
tout mais certainement il ya une raison
ça veut pas dire que je soutenais
l'ensemble des dispositions mais il y
avait une ambition que j'ai toujours
partagé qui était à un moment donné
d'avoir une discussion globale sur le
nouveau paysage audiovisuel et arrêtez
de mettre des pansements la loi de 86
avait plutôt envisagé dans sa globalité
un environnement qui a été plus que
révolutionner depuis pour avoir une
cohérence de ce paysage privé public et
c'est donc ce débat était nécessaire
pour la société tout simplement puisque
les médias ont pris une place importante
et dans son rapport aussi aux plate
formes aux nouveaux usages aux nouvelles
technologies tout cela c'était bien
d'avoir une discussion globale on n'aura
pas cette critique qu'elle vous pour de
longs temps pour moi c'est pas
spécifique à ce gouvernement
à chaque fois on a dit que tin can a
commencé il faudra une grande loi
audiovisuelle pour etc
et à la fin on avait une petite loi
toujours mais c'est pour cela d'ailleurs
que je le dis je je le présageait avant
alors là c'est un petit pois qui
s'attaquent un problème que je soutiens
absolument puisque dès 2013 j'étais au
centre d'une polémique parce que dans la
loi sur l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel
le public
j'avais envisageait de déposer un
amendement au sénat pour la fusion de
l'hadopi et du csa partant d'un constat
qui s'est imposé finalement qu' on ne
peut pas considérer que quand les
contenus audiovisuels circulent encore
plus sur le net que sur nous nous télé
classique
ben le csa il il va réguler que sur les
télés c'est pas possible on a vu des
aberrations du type faire une loi qui
interdit la pub avant les émissions pour
enfants font sur le service public et
aucun alors que c'est déjà pas mal
régulé un service public au terme de
contenu des tic etc
et puis rien sur youtube où les jeunes
sont et les enfants sont là toute la
journée beaucoup plus que sur les télés
qui ont cette régulation est là aucune
régulation donc je pense que c'était
très important un moment qui est quelque
chose de global de cohérent pour les
contenus audiovisuels et je soutiens
cette cela avec pas une condition mais
quelque chose qui devrait aller avec
c'est que si la fusion si le cs l'art
comme demain va devoir avoir cette
gigantesque tâche de régulation de ski
et sur les réseaux sociaux y compris
alors vous imaginez bien que pour que
cette tâche puisse s'accomplir de façon
crédible et efficace il faut des moyens
énormes les normes quand tous les cas
plus important que ce qu'il a et que ce
qui est prévu dans le budget donc on
sera attentif
j'espère tous au budget qui va venir que
avec cette nouvelle dimension
on ne soit pas dans un budget qui rend
impossible sa tâche voilà pour cet
aspect important
deuxième aspect j'étais pour la
réduction d'une ou deux membres du csa
donc on est passé à 7
c'est une question d'efficacité etc
mais l'état d'esprit du csa tel qu'il
existait tel que nous l'avons réformer
était pour que les instances qui nomment
notamment sur l'indépendance qu'il
fallait que lui-même sont indépendants
et donc y avait une nomination par le
président c'était le président et puis
les deux champs de nommer les trois
autres chacune ça faisait six sur sept
membres nommés par le parlement dans sa
diversité et sa donné cette garantie
d'ailleurs on l'a vu le csa n'a jamais
été contestée dans son pluralisme depuis
or là on reste à 7
mais il ya de nomination par le conseil
d'état et la cour de cassation
donc le parlement est affaibli de fait
c'est une réalité qui la donnent moins
jamais pour réfléchisse si il faut ces
deux là et je le concède qu'on ne baisse
pas tous les cas vous voyez ce débat con
parce que l'époque est à
l'affaiblissement du parlement dans tous
les domaines où le m'arrête pas de le
dire ici donc je ne vais pas cautionner
le fait qu on l'affaiblisse voilà on va
me dire mais tu es un peu obtus
non il ya des signes politiques qui s'en
voit si on déséquilibre à ce point la
place du parlement
dans cette le c7 ya un vrai sujet
politique surtout dans le contexte
actuel où nous sommes trop souvent
contournée et vous avez évoqué
d'ailleurs les contournements
on va dire que on va te pas la loi
grande loi envisagée mais tout passe par
ordonnance ou par décision unilatérale
de l'exécutif je donne un exemple on
décide de suprise de redéfinir le
périmètre de france télévisions de fait
puisque on supprime deux chaînes ça
passe pas dans la loi c'est une décision
gouvernementale et nous on a nos yeux
pour pleurer
alors qu'on est unanime tous ceux qui
sont penchés sur cette question disent
haut et fort avec notre président de
commission ou encore dernièrement
que france 4 il faut il faut faut le
maintenir une chaîne jeunesse et puis
les ordonnances qui quitte à nous on a
donné l'exemple
il ya un an au sénat en faisant que on
accepte alors qu'on est contre les
ordonnances qu'on est dite pour aller
vite pour aider le secteur
on va quand même accepter leur donnant
lé paru quand même qu'on descend et
temps d'arriver l'odm en tous les cas
comme quoi les ordonnances ne va pas
plus vite que la loi est très souvent
donc voilà je voulais conclure en vous
disant que dans ce débat des sujets
annexes
enfin annexes qui touche à l'audiovisuel
ont effectivement peuvent être frappés
d'anticonstitutionnalité d'articles 40
etc
on essaiera d'éviter mais on essaiera
d'éviter ce piège mais sans que ces
débats ne soient pas dans l'hémicycle
donc moi j'appelle ici à une grande
ouverture sur la façon dont on va
apprécier ce qui recevra le parseval
parce qu'on peut pas interdire tous les
débats dont on est frustré mais que
l'assemblée a eu par contre est la
question du sport je soutiens votre
ligne en général un sur le piratage qui
est de s'attaquer aux sites aussi qui en
font commerce aussi de pirate est
d'ailleurs s'ils avaient passé si tu
aurais pas de consommateurs de ces sites
qui se mettent eux-mêmes dans
l'illégalité
certes mais je suis très par contre on
va dire que on est mélangé le sport le
piratage concernant le sport qui est un
vrai sujet qui mérite loi tête avec ce
dont on discute pourquoi parce que quand
on pirate à culture le cinéma etc
alors que des millions de gens en ville
pour vraiment pour créer il ya quelque
chose où on peut faire prendre
conscience à la jeunesse c'est pas
possible pour qu'ils comprennent que
speed
pis quelqu'un qui veut en vivre ses
droits d'auteur et c'est le sport dans
un système où on accepte que le sport le
plus populaire qui fédère le plus le
peuple il dans sa profondeur et ses
hôtes des origines sociales les plus
modestes
par exemple foot ne soit plus accessible
gratuitement en temps de pandémie on
peut même pas aller au stade avec une
place à quelques dizaines d'euros dans
dans dans un virage
eh bien on est interdit de pouvoir
assister à cela ce qui fait communion et
c'est parce que il faut payer il faut
payer plusieurs fois si tu veux voir
l'europe si tu veux voir lequel
championnat trans et c'est donc dans un
système où tout jeune qui a envie de
voir n'a que la possibilité du streaming
et il existe compris par des gens qui on
profite ne pas s'attaquer à ce système
où des gens seraient payées des millions
sont pas volés les joueurs 1 on peut
dire que ils vivent bien par rapport aux
artistes pied
mélanger les deux problèmes alors qu'on
s'attaque pas l'économie du sport et au
fait qu' il faut rendre accessible le
sport à la majorité de nos concitoyens
vient perturber le message qu'on veut
pédagogique qu'on veut envoyer quand on
se bat contre le piratage merci michel
logique
merci monsieur le président madame
ministre bien sûr très heureux de de
vous retrouver juste quelques précisions
sur sur ce texte et surtout votre
position déjà serré qu'on peut regretter
le périmètre de la loire saturday
beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui les
périmètres est très réduit et d'autant
plus qu'on veut faire rentrer beaucoup
de choses dedans donc là et c'est vrai
qu'il ya quelque chose d'un petit peu
paradoxal la deuxième chose bien sûr sur
les sites sportifs
illégaux le piratage je vais aussi dans
même sens que david assouline et en plus
c'est devenu d'autant plus important
dans cette période de pandémie on n'a
pas d'autre choix que d'être devant son
poste de télévision
et en plus c'est vrai que alors après
avec la crise de mediapro mais c'est
vrai que ça coûte très cher aujourd'hui
de pouvoir suivre des matches de
football à la télévision donc vraiment
on ne ressent un très très vigilants sur
les moyens sur les moyens qui seront mis
pour éviter ce piratage bien sûr tout à
fait favorable à la fusion du csa et de
l'hadopi on en parlait depuis un petit
moment déjà donc là on entre dans le vif
du sujet dont ça nous permet d'être très
efficace
et puis par était injuste en or et une
question peu plus un peu plus précise
sur l'article 17 et les risques liés sur
la recherche de l'exploitation
dans le cas d'une vente d'oeuvres le
conseil d'état estimé dans son avis que
les obligations vient souvent imposé à
l'acheteur devait être assorti d'une
compensation financière de l'état
or rien n'est prévu aujourd'hui dans le
texte merci pour votre réponse
chez rémy va qui veut derrière son écran
jérémy
oui bonjour merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre
est-ce que vous m'entendez viennent tout
d'abord j'ai eu quelques soucis de
connexion jusqu'à présent donc j'espère
que autant céder à montendre au centre
c'est merci merci donc j'aurai trois
questions pour vous madame la ministre
tout d'abord sur la protection des
catalogues est ce qu'on peut imaginer un
système de préhension par l'état
d'oeuvre française et si oui sur quelle
base sur quelle base de choix 2 afin de
les protéger surtout de les rendre
accessibles
le projet de loi prévoit que le
ministère pourrait imposer des
conditions de l'exploitation de l'oeuvre
pour éviter qu'elle ne tombe dans
l'oubli mais cela une bosse carmen
qu'elle soit réellement accessible ma
deuxième question vous y allez en partie
répondu concerne toujours la protection
des catalogues
qu'en sera-t-il en matière de
coproduction imaginons par exemple le
film conte financé par une scie studio
et netflix
si le groupe de nicolas de tavernot
envisager de céder une partie de ses
droits netflix est ce que le ministère
aura alors son mot à dire
et en fait un très rapidement une
dernière question sur la concentration
des médias est ce que la jauge l'actuel
prévu par le csa parce que les jauges
pardon actuel prévue par le sap vont
être amenés à bouger je vous remercie
laure darcos merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je bien évidemment je
suis très heureux de vous revoir et et
j'espère que vous allez quand même faire
attention dans les semaines qui viennent
c'est votre santé avant tout même si on
est ravi de vous retrouver moi je
voudrais alors bien évidemment je suis
totalement d'accord avec mes collègues
sur le fait que nous sommes un peu
frustrés sur le périmètre de la loi et
je trouve que les questions posées par
le rapporteur sur la tnt valent quand
même d'être posée et donc sur le
périmètre lui-même je pense que on y
reviendra sûrement
je pense que c'était en même temps très
important que cette loi ait lieu pour
hadopi et pour le csa hadopi l'ancien
président de viser que ça devenait très
compliqué maintenant ne serait ce que en
termes de personnel de motivation des
équipes
donc je pense que vraiment pour l'art
comme à venir c'était important de de
pouvoir être enfin d'aboutir à cette
transformation
moi je voulais revenir sur un sujet très
précis qui concernait les dispositions
relatives à la protection des catalogues
audivisuel remarquable je me fais là
dessus vraiment le porte parole des
sociétés de production qui ont trouvé
que ils ont été très surpris en fait
cette disposition dans cette dans ce
texte sans avoir eu de concertation
préalable du tout avec aucune des
sociétés françaises détentrices de
catalogue de visuels en tout cas c'est
ce qu'ils m'ont dit donc le j'attends ma
mini ce que vous puissiez m'en dire plus
et elles sont déjà tellement fragilisé
par la crise sanitaire la baisse
drastique des aides du cnc pour le
secteur patrimonial d'ailleurs ils
craignent que ça s'arrête après après
ça remet en cause aussi faim la
définition et même de catalogue
audiovisuel remarquable qu'est ce que
c'est que cette définition le fait qu on
garantira l'accès au public ça
contrevient quand même au code de la
propriété intellectuelle qui met à la
charge du producteur une obligation de
moyens et non obligation de résultat
tous ces sujets sont en tout cas assez
anxiogène pour eux et je voulais que
vous puissiez développé un petit peu
plus et voir comment on pourra faire
pour que ces sociétés de productions
françaises qui ne sont pas absolument
pas sur le fond opposé à cette mise à
disposition puisse être rassurés quant à
leur société et leur exploitation merci
et enfin julien bargeton julien
autant pas à la menthe en débat c'est
bon t'es si que c'est bon bonjour à
toutes et à tous et puis ravi de vous
retrouver - là ministre charles roselyne
et puis là des mots d'encouragement mais
aussi et c'est à dire de reprendre ses
activités mais c'est bien aussi de les
reprendre progressivement il de ceux de
se reposer en tout cas vraiment vraiment
ravis et j'étais dans ce déplacement
aussi dans dans une école du 20e
arrondissement et voilà je suis vraiment
très content que nous puissions échanger
par serait ce que nouveau projet de loi
le président comme d'avis que cet état
c'est être avait il est vrai que le
nouveau projet de loi que vous présentez
est plus resserré que le précédent il
conserve néanmoins vous trouvera des
dispositions consensuelles et ambitieuse
de l'ancien red loi notamment ça a été
cité sur le piratage avec la fusion
d'hadopi et du mil du csa dont nous
parlerons ou et qui va animer le débat
le projet de loi précédent avait pour
ambition affichée également la
souveraineté culturelle à l'ère
numérique
une notion qui n'apparaît plus dans
l'intitulé du nouveau projet de loi
pouvez vous nous dire et nous repréciser
quels sont les outils du texte qui
permettront de renforcer cette
souveraineté culturelle qui est d'autant
plus indispensable à l'ère du numérique
merci beaucoup voilà madame la ministre
toutes les questions ou ont été posées
je vais vous laisser la parole si vous
souhaitez faire une pause à ce stade
bien entendu c'est comme vous le
souhaitez mais danger on a en écoutant
les sénatrices et sénateurs
j'ai repris mon souffle d'abord je
voulais remercier l'ensemble des
sénatrices et sénateurs et sénatrices et
sénateurs du mans
interrogé de m'avoir transmis leurs
voeux de bon rétablissement
effectivement je suis toujours en
convalescence mais
je suis aussi à la manoeuvre pour gérer
toutes les choses si importante dans
cette période sanitaire compliqué mener
les travaux qui vont permettre la
réouverture des deux culturel que nous
attendons tous ça et me déployait et sur
tous les sujets qui accompagnent ou
d'ailleurs qui sont oubliés je le note
on se focalise sur beaucoup sur la crise
sanitaire et c'est tout à fait
compréhensible mais je mène aussi toutes
sortes de sujets en même temps ans en
particulier par exemple au plan de
relance sur les landes crédit du
patrimoine d'autres sujets que vous avez
vus à travers la communication du
ministère ne serait-ce qu hier en
forçant la possibilité pour les signer
les cinémas ou les radios
territorialisée d'accéder à lezennes
alors qu'elles ont été gravement menacée
par la crise sanitaire
oui dans leur heureuse dans leurs
recettes dans leurs recettes de
publicité donc je veux être complètement
complètement à la manoeuvre david
assouline je me suis expliqué sur les
raisons qui ont conduit à ce texte
resserré je note que vous l'avez signalé
signaler que dès 2013
vous étiez un militant de la fusion de
l'hadopi et du csa bien entendu ça ne
relève pas de ce texte qui n'est pas un
texte budgétaire
j'ai bien retenu au delà du soutien que
vous apportez depuis pratiquement dix
ans à cette fusion
cela nécessitera des moyens renforcés
cela ne relève pas donc de ce texte
architectural mais les besoins de la
future art comme les marges de gros
services du premier ministre et je ne
doute pas de votre vigilance sur ce
sujet vous avez également interrogé
ainsi que d'autres de vos collègues sur
la composition de la colle donc le
collège de la future art comme
comprendra
outre son président deux membres
désignés par le président de l'assemblée
nationale et deux par le président du
sénat deux magistrats chargés notamment
de la réponse graduée prévue par le code
de la propriété intellectuelle
je rappelle que dès le projet de loi de
2006 live
la composition du collège de la future
art comme rêveront tel objectif ne pas
augmenter le nombre de ses membres
ce texte introduisait au sein du collège
de l'alstom à magistrat désigné par le
président de la république chargée de la
réponse graduée un membre du collège de
la recette pour maintenir le nombre de
membres du collège à 7
le projet de loi réduisait bond de 3,2
le nombre de demandes est signé par les
présidents des deux assemblées
le présent projet de loi maintient ce
principe en l'adaptant il ne prévoit
plus la présence au sein du collège de
l'art comme d'amandes de l'arsel ni la
présente pas si ardemment de la pomme
dans le collège de l'arcep comme les
deux autorités ont souligné dans leur
vie respectifs
le renforcement de la coopération entre
l est déjà largement engagé et rend
moins nécessaire l'instauration de ce
mécanisme complexe de participations
croisées
en revanche le texte prévoit que le
collège accueille deux nouveaux membres
désignés respectivement par le vice
président du conseil d'état et le
premier président de la cour de
cassation en lieu et place de deux des
six membres nommés par les assemblées
parlementaires
pourquoi avons-nous prévu cette présence
la présence de ces magistrats au sein de
cette nouvelle instance
la présence au sein du collège de
membres ayant statut de magistrat a
semblé tout à fait souhaitable au
gouvernement et ce pour deux raisons
principales
au regard des anges le 21 ans juridique
attaché à la mission de réponse graduée
aujourd'hui dévolues à la commission de
protection des droits de l'hadopi qui
est composée de magistrats et de la
nécessité d'apporter toutes les
garanties nécessaires dans la mise en
oeuvre cette procédure de la dure
pré pénale la sensibilité des atteintes
à la vie privée à la liberté de
communication justifie de ses fonctions
soit confiée à des personnes présentant
des garanties renforcer la présence de
magistrats au sein du collège de l'art
comme et de plus parfaitement cohérente
avec les nouvelles missions au delà du
champ de la propriété intellectuelle qui
sont confiées à l'autorité hier par la
loi relative à la manipulation de
l'information demain par la loi
comportant le respect des principes
républicains
après ma part le digital services act en
matière de liberté d'expression lutte
contre la haine en ligne lutte contre la
désinformation
cela justifie pleinement le collet de
l'art comme puissent bénéficier l
expertise de deux membres magistrats
par ailleurs le csa s'est interrogé dans
son avis sur la question de savoir qui
des deux magistrats ou serait le
titulaire de la réponse graduée et qui
serait le suppléant
le texte a été précisé depuis sur ce
point puisqu'il est prévu que l'art
comme désignera celui des deux
magistrats y sera titulaire pendant les
trois premières années de son mandat
puis c'est l'autre magistrat qui le
remplacera pendant les trois années
suivant voilà cette précision qui est
important alors à votre suite david
assouline
michel laugier s'est aussi intéressée
sur la question du sport que vous aviez
souligné david assouline et que michel
2e laugier a également souligné
je trouve quand même un peu curieux que
vous me les litchis pour une sorte de
droit au piratage des manifestations
sportives
ça me parait étrange je signale
d'ailleurs que bien entendu les
dispositifs qui convainc le piratage sur
les manifestations sportives
vous le verrez vous le voyez dans le
texte n'ont pas la même nature que ce
qui concerne les biens culturels ou les
manifestations culturelles par
définition évidemment le bien culturel
est un bien pérenne alors que les
manifestations sportives s'inscrit le
plus tôt dans une source s'inscrit
totalement dans une saison sportive et
leurs intérêts diminue évidemment pour
ne pas dire disparaît sitôt la
manifestation en direct fait le sport
pardon n'hésitez pas seulement les
grandes manifestations sportives de type
football c'est aussi tout un catalogue
de manifestations est il vraiment je ne
peux pas défendre une idée de la d'une
sorte de droit ou kherrata j'ai limité
des manifestations sportives qui
pourrait être gravement dommageable pour
l'ensemble du sport français
on ne pourra pas faire de distinction
entre les différentes manifestations
sportives
selon qu'elles relèvent de recettes
importantes ou de recettes par an
quasiment inexistantes alors des
questions ont été posées sur un sujet
qui me tient particulièrement à coeur
par à la fois gérer ni baci et par laure
darcos sur la protection des catalogues
et sans doute neige pas été assez
complète sur ce sujet dans ma
présentation liminaire un point pour
l'heure darcos
le terme de remarquables n'apparaît plus
dans le texte
vous avez raison leur darcos parce que
ça peut poser un problème de définition
juridique
à partir de quand et ton une oeuvre
remarquable tout ça d'ailleurs à ce
torrent dispositions largement subjectif
donc il n'y a plus il n'y a plus la
notion de remarques 410 protection des
catalogues de nos arbres
cinématographique
vraiment c'est un enjeu qui est
présentement en cours les français à la
fois en termes de patrimoine dit dans
cité de souveraineté nationale et je
répondrai déjà en partie à
l'interrogation qui m'a été posée par
julien bargeton c'est évidemment un
élément tout à fait important de
souveraineté nationale
alors j'ai évoqué à travers des grandes
sociétés comme gaumont pathé studio
studio canal
les grandes oeuvres des cinémas français
alors aujourd'hui il faut savoir que
public à la garantie d'avoir accès aux
offres françaises car les producteurs
établis en france qui possède six heures
sont tenues donc à une obligation
j'ouvre les guillemets de recherche
l'exploitation suivi prévue par le code
de la propriété intellectuelle
cette obligation essentielle leur impose
de conserver les supports des oeuvres en
bon état et de fournir leurs meilleurs
efforts pour que l'oeuvre puissent être
exploitées et donc vus par le public en
france et à l'étranger
alors j'ai évoqué à ces risques de
grandes sociétés production qui peuvent
être achetés mais simplement leur
catalogue peuvent être rachetées par des
entreprises qui ne sont pas tenus en
l'état du droit à cette obligation de
recherche d'exploitations suisses
simplement pas ce sont des sociétés
étrangères mme ou parce qu'il ne
s'agisse pas société de production on
pense évidemment au fonds
d'investissement a suivi les oeuvres
achetées par des entreprises américaines
ou chinoises pourraient du jour au
lendemain être inaccessible au public
français
ces acheteurs pourraient décider de les
retirer temporairement du marché ou
encore je les dis d'exploiter seulement
les str oduction l'épurant tu as
vraiment ce risque est d'autant plus
inacceptable que les oeuvres françaises
sont le plus souvent pas dire totalement
était financée par les fonds publics
notamment bien le soutien du cnc ou les
différentes dispositions fiscales
par ailleurs je voulais dire que les
concertations ont été menées elles ont
été menées par le cnc et l oms
elles continuent à être menées par le
cnc avec les différents les différentes
parties prenantes sur ce sujet qui s'est
juste nous sommes également à
disposition pour améliorer le texte dont
il y avait eu concertation
je ne comprends pas cette polémique les
elle a été absolument mener
je reprends donc mon propos nous allons
donc soumettre les oeuvres
cinématographiques et audiovisuelles un
dispositif de protection
quand elles sont rachetés par des
entreprises et aujourd'hui ne sont pas
tenues donc à cette question
d'exploitations suisses
l'article 17 étant donc à toutes les
personnes qui rachète une ou plusieurs
oeuvres françaises
l'obligation de recherche de cotation
suivi ça existe uniquement pour un des
producteurs établis en france tout
projet de cession d'avoir doit faire
l'objet d'une déclaration préalable ou
pas de mes services ou moins six mois
avant la date de l'opération envisagée
ces chinois permet de vérifier que
l'acheteur présente bien toutes les
garanties pour assurer la recherche
d'une votation suivi et si ce n'est pas
le cas des garanties peuvent lui être
imposée par une commission de protection
de l'accès aux heures
c'est un dispositif nécessaire c'est un
dispositif proportionnée nous ne
pouvions ou pas d'ailleurs vous le
reconnaîtrez en l'état du droit aller
plus loin notamment la liberté de
circulation des capitaux tels que des
unités dans le droit de niro pn nous
interdit de soumettre les projets de
rachat à une autorisation préalable et
de faire juridiquement obstacle à la
vente
ce projet est soutenu par toutes les
organisations de cinéastes et pour de
nombreux producteurs
c'est un premier pas important dans la
défense de notre souveraineté culturelle
je redis pour ma part une coursive on la
réflexion sur la défense de nos acquis
culturels stratégie
je pense en particulier à la protection
de notre réseau de salles de cinéma la
protection des actifs il dit
stratégique est aussi je viens dans
l'entente en question de souveraineté
nationale
finalement l'ensemble du texte est une
défense de la souveraineté
l'interdiction du piratage la création
d'une autorité indépendante qui garantit
des mesures efficaces sûrs sur cette
liste on peut le piratage la protection
la protection des catalogues
s'inscrivant dans l' architecture
globale que les définit au début de marc
de mon propos liminaire tout cela est
une question de souveraineté nationale
et je crois qu'il ya je suis toujours
surprise dans ce débat sur ces sujets
que on oppose trop souvent le droit des
consommateurs à ce texte parce que le
droit des consommateurs
c'est aussi le droit d'avoir une
souveraineté sur des biens culturels et
de garder la propriété de c02 culturel
pourquoi certains ça dimitile de perte
de souveraineté dans la recherche
pharmaceutique ou la construction
automobile et lestrem finalement les
biens culturels à disposition sont les
créateurs soient rémunérés pour le
travail et la créativité dans titres
dont ils ont fait preuve
ce débat ne pensais pas qu'il est absent
qu'il est réglé il est toujours devant
nous
c'est pour ça que les dispositions de ce
texte sont particulièrement importantes
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur
merci madame la ministre je crois que
les propos contenus deux collègues sur
le sport n'était pas tout à fait ce que
vous avez entendu mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler
la mort rapide david assouline d'autres
questions oui juste une petite mise au
point madame la ministre je n'appelle
pas au piratage ni ne soutient les
pirates
j'ai dit très exactement je trouve
dommage que la façon d'aborder le sport
à la télévision soit dans cette fois
sous le prisme de la lutte contre le
piratage qui est d'ailleurs existe dans
une autre loi sur le sport et vient
dénaturer le débat parce que il y a le
fida dessus cinq ans à la demande du
gouvernement j'ai remis un rapport pour
faire que le sport soit plus accessible
à la télévision et de façon gratuite et
que je n'ai jamais vu la suite de ce qui
est normalement rue du décidé par votre
gouvernement puisqu'il me l'a dit à peu
près tous les ans que ça allait venir
notamment un décret sur les événements
importants et que pas de réponse là
dessus pas dépôt de loi par contre sur
le piratage il y a quelque chose qui
vient au mauvais endroit
donc je suis contre le piratage mais je
suis pour que les gens puissent regarder
le sport de façon démocratique
précision donnée moi je voudrais sortir
quelques instants du texte jeu de l'oie
je crois qu'on a on a fini les questions
je voudrais par noyade madame de marco
qui avaient encore une question à vous
poser sur le projet de loi oui merci
merci madame la ministre
voilà moi ça je reviens sur ce projet de
loi sur le bilan d'hadopi qui a montré
quand même que l'outil le plus efficace
pour lutter contre le piratage des
oeuvres et de proposer une offre légale
et séduisante
alors il est probable que n'explique ce
a davantage contribué à la baisse du
piratage qu'hadopi me semble t'il alors
concernant les retransmissions sportives
l'éclatement de l'offre largement
contribué à diminuer l'accès légal au
match en direct
favorisant donc du coup un retour de
plates formes de piratage
pensez vous que ce projet de loi
permettrait de développer dans
courage et davantage l'offre légale de
contenus et quels moyens pourrait être
envisagée pour cela on va agir c'est la
triste peux me rappeler votre dernière
question j'ai eu une interruption de son
sur votre la dernière partie de votre
intervention la vacation et en ce projet
de loi permettra t-il de développer et
d'encourager davantage l'offre légale de
contenus et quels moyens peuvent être
tilleur envisagée pour cela très
rapidement sur votre question je veux
que le pirate a augmenté de la même
façon que la preuve les propositions
commerciales de netflix ont augmenté
donc crise fennell x de la diminution
des piratages jeu bâclé schiele le
confiants quant à leurs chevaux légale
de contenus sais pas ce n'est pas le
sujet du projet de loi à l'augmenter
l'offre légale de contenus
moi ce que je note c'est que la france
grâce à des mécanismes extrêmement
puissant
dès la création cinématographique et
audiovisuelle participe comme aucun
autre pays européen par des mécanismes
qui sont des mécanismes publics à la
création d'une offre diversifiée et de
qualité de contenu dans ces deux
secteurs et que on a vu d'ailleurs à
travers cette crise sanitaire
à quel point ces politiques qui ont
permis finalement que le cinéma français
reste le dernier cinéma européen ça veut
pas dire qu'il ya pas des films qui sont
fait leur boulot délire bien mais qu'on
peut dire qu'ils y ait en france une
industrie cinématographique 7,7 cette
politique publique a été à l'oeuvre elle
n'a pas défailli pendant la crise
elle a permis de soutenir les créations
elle a permis de soutenir le tournage
des fièvres que j'ai autorisé que j'ai
permis de financer
elle a protégé le système de district
mission des salles de cinéma à notre
avis en 2000 salles de cinéma dont 6000
écran et toute la politique que je
venais de protéger à tous les stades de
l'industrie cinématographie de protéger
et audiovisuel de protéger cet autre
ligue
cette offre légale de contenus donc
véritablement je crois qu'on peut être
collectivement fier d'un système que
d'ailleurs sur tous les bancs et dans
toutes les sensibilités
nous avons défendu et que nous
transmettons à travers tous les aléas
des changements de majorité
madame la ministre vous le permettez moi
j'avais deux questions à vous poser mais
qui non non non pas un lien avec le
projet de loi mais qui sont plus des
questions d'actualité la première
concerne culturebox initiative de france
télévisions que vous aviez
personnellement beaucoup soutenu mais
qui normalement arrive à échéance à la
fin du mois d'avril
malheureusement la crise sanitaire est
toujours présente et les restrictions en
matière de d'activités culturelles de
même est ce que le gouvernement envisage
de soutenir la prolongation de deux
cultures boxe pendant quelques semaines
quelques mois et puis la deuxième
question on lit souvent dans la presse
mais vous allez infirmer ou confirmer
que l'état priviligierait concernant la
vente de m6 de rachat par tf1 comme
c'est dit avec insistance par la presse
je me permets de vous poser la question
pour savoir si un scénario privilégié
par le gouvernement
il faut que je rallume première question
monsieur le président sur culturebox
nous sommes en train d'analyser des
shows effectivement si la crise continue
je pense que la prolongation de deux
cultures box est une une chose à
envisager vous savez que j'ai beaucoup
milité pour la création de cette chaîne
et que
nous avons avec roch olivier maistre
d'ailleurs que je remercie à ce sujet
puisque je sais que je crois il va vous
rejoindre datant en quelques minutes et
ils écoutent peuvent être nos échanges
que je remercie pour avoir permis de
façon vraiment très rapide la création
de postures boxe nous sommes en train de
faire le bilan et l'analyse de tout cela
nous n'avons pas à ce stade deux
scénarios privilégiés et les laits
comment dirais-je les indiscrétions les
bruits de couloir ne sont pas des choses
dont je vais faire état à ce stade mais
je reviendrai bien entendu volontiers de
berne ou lorsque les choses seront
officialisées est stabilisé bien entendu
monsieur le président vous pouvez
compter sur moi le ministre lâchant pas
mon plaisir de vous retrouver en forme
ascendante
je veux préciser que le projet de loi
est de bon aloi
toutefois dans l'aspect de protection de
l'oeuvre à l'heure du numérique
m'interroge
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que nombre
de jeunes artistes créateurs artisans
sont contraints à fall communication de
diffuser leurs oeuvres sur les réseaux
sociaux
cette pratique bien que de nature à les
exposer aux cages ya et à toute sorte de
dépossession volant création est
incontournable pour quiconque
aujourd'hui se lance dans une carrière
créative certaines grandes marques de
prêt à porter se sont déjà fait
remarquer par des faits litigieux à cet
égard déjà le créateur puisque plus de
ça donne également à ces pratiques de
curation alors ma question est simple
comment protéger nuages des oeuvres sur
les réseaux sociaux et la com de rater
le doter d'une telle mission
je vous en remercie j'étais au lieu de
le rallumer vous êtes sergent tirs de
colons au coeur d'un débat
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où un
créateur choisi pour des raisons
commerciales d'abandonner sa possibilité
de défendre sa propriété intellectuelle
on peut pas le supplée dans cette
démarche bien entendu il ya un certain
nombre de support sur lequel nous
pouvons intervenir et nous avons l'art
comment dirais-je nous en discuterons
fond lors de l'examen du projet de loi
mais véritablement si quelqu'un décide
qu'il est plus intéressant pour lui de
perdre sandra la propriété
intellectuelle pour assurer lui at-il de
mai à meilleur rendement de sa capacité
créatrice comment l'en empêcher vous
posez une question fort mais c'est aussi
la liberté du créateur
comment dirais-je là comme puisse
intervenir dans le cadre des réseaux
sociaux
déjà on a un groupe qu'on a déjà bien du
mal à a essayé d'apporter un peu de
moralité des tic dix ans pour être ont
utilisé un mot amour moins controversés
sur les réseaux sociaux
là je pense que vous finiriez à l'art
comme une obligation démesurée et
d'estradiol incapable de remplir
merci madame le ministre il n'y a plus
de question cette fois-ci
eh bien il nous reste à vous remercier
des réponses que vous avez apporté à
l'alitement à la commission et puis
comme je disais tout à l'heure ce débat
s'ouvre sur ce texte grâce à cette
audition de cet après midi et nous
aurons bien sûr à coeur de le poursuivre
pendant les semaines qui viennent
jusqu'à au débat dans l'hémicycle le 18
mai à très bientôt madame la ministre
est encore une fois on rétablit merci
[Musique]